[Music]
ambassador to the united nations is a
prestigious job
it is significant and it is influential
representing the united states of
america and high states negotiations
around the world
it has also turned out to be a launching
pad of sorts to bigger and some might
argue
better things take susan rice for
example or samantha power
those were president obama's picks for
u.n ambassador republicans took issue
with them
at the time but their concerns were
ultimately dismissed
similar concerns were raised last month
about president biden's pick for top
diplomat
linda thomas greenfield specifically
when it comes to a speech she gave
in 2019 in praise of chinese investments
overseas
she has since tried to distance herself
from those comments but will it work
joining me now former ambassador to the
united stations and former governor of
the great state of south carolina nikki
haley governor haley how are you
hey trey it's great to be with you
thank you i am not going to ask you to
comment on your successor unless you
want to
i will ask you to comment on china and
what kind of message we should be
sending them
um in terms of our relationship with
them
well i think it's important look i think
the issue with china is more important
than
just one speech that that the new
ambassador may have
given what i'm concerned about is the
biden administration
understanding what a true threat china
is the department of defense
came out and said that the chinese
military were ahead of the pentagon on
three things
china has the largest naval fleet in the
world
they have the most advanced air defense
system
in the world and they literally have one
of the most robust
land missiles programs in the world i
mean when you look at that
and then you go to the fact that they
have no treaty to kind of reign
china in yet biden turns around gets us
back into the new start treaty with
russia
that brings us in doesn't allow us to
compete with china
doesn't include china in it and oh by
the way you just expanded it five years
russia is thrilled china's thrilled this
is the problem that we have
you get into the paris climate agreement
yet you're not going to have
china turn around and have to follow the
same regulations as the united states
my concern is that the bible
administration is not taking china
seriously
this feels like it's going right back to
what it was where they just
assumed that china would be okay if we
tried to talk to them
china is there they want to be communist
china
they want to rule the world literally
and we need vision we need to be smart
about it we need to be strategic about
it and we need to understand
that they need to be held accountable
not one word yet
has been said about the fact that they
put this virus on the whole world no one
is asking china to be accountable for
that
it's time for us to step up it's not
about small things it's about
big issues and how we take on china
going forward
let me pivot and ask you about another
country iran how do we go
from killing an iranian general because
they were such an adversary to now being
willing to sit down at the table
and discuss their nuclear arsenal
how do you go from killing a general to
talking to them
trey this is truly dangerous i mean you
look at the fact that they're looking at
getting into
back into the iran deal what does that
mean that means you're going to lift
all of the sanctions that we've put on
iran well
the sanctions that we put on them weaken
them in terms of they weren't able to
fund terrorism
and weakened their economy so much that
they've got the iranian people
demonstrating in the streets
against the regime that's what we wanted
you're going to jump back in the iran
deal but you're not going to ask them to
leave syria
you're not going to ask them to stop
their nuclear program you're not going
to
ask them to stop their missile program
you're not going to ask them to stop
funding terrorism
and you're going to get back into a deal
and that's
literally obama 2.0 that's going right
back to the same situation and
this is a a bigger issue so now you're
going back to
you're actually hurting our friends
israel and the arab countries
that worked with us on getting these
sanctions back on iran that worked with
us
on trying to hold back terrorism and the
concern i have is
what you have is that by the
administration is snubbing our friends
like israel
but they're cozying up to enemies like
iran do you know biden's been
in office for two weeks now he has yet
to call the israeli prime minister one
of our
closest allies it i mean i just
i don't understand the logic whether
it's china whether it's iran
any of the foreign policy that he's
doing is really not being
about strong america it's about just
being complacent
with those that are our enemies
i want to ask you to put on your old
governor hat i'm going to play a clip
from another republican governor ron
desantis and then on the other side of
it i want to ask you two questions
so you had the new york post to run it
and you couldn't get any traction you
couldn't get any reach on it
because big tech put their thumb on the
scale so that was true what they said at
the time
oh it was it was it's a conspiracy or
it's based on
on on hacked information are you kidding
me
you're trying to tell me if there was
hacked information that could damage me
you guys wouldn't print it give me a
break you can whiz on my leg but don't
tell me it's raining you guys would
print it every single day if you could
and big tech would allow it to
proliferate every single day 20 set 24
7.
governor i watched you navigate a
primary
field full of men when you became the
governor i have watched you fight with
our south carolina general assembly when
they needed to be fought with
so i know you're tough how would you how
should republicans fight with both big
tech
and the media that you know ronnie is
right we perceive to be biased against
us
i mean we have to we have to speak about
the truth we've got to call them out and
say look
you know here everybody's talking about
unity right like that's the new buzzword
is everybody wants to talk about unity
but first you have to talk about you
know if you're going to talk about the
division
of republicans and democrats how are we
going to hold the media accountable how
are we going to hold big tech
accountable
they have to i'm not talking about
government coming in they have to
acknowledge
their responsibility in all of the
division
and it used to be a time where the left
was all about freedom of speech
now they want to reign that in you just
had aoc recently say that she wants a
commission
that will turn around and reign in any
of the right
wing news programs you have they are
literally they just had a call out they
want to cancel
fox news off of regular cable stations
fox news and other conservative outlets
they now want to take off of some of the
cable networks because they don't think
that it's safe to have on or they don't
think that it's right
what happened to the fact that the media
is supposed to give us the facts
not tell us what to think not tell us
how to think just give us the facts
give us both sides the american people
are smart enough to make those decisions
for ourselves we don't need the media
telling us and we don't need big tech
partnering with the media in terms of
what they think is the right speech and
the wrong speech
we are the greatest country in the world
at the u.n
i saw how envious all the countries were
about freedom of speech this literally
has every country in the world
scratching their head
saying what is happening in america it's
time for the media
to do their job it's time for big tech
to do their job
and i think every governor every
politician every
private citizen needs to be calling them
out for what they're doing it's wrong
and this is not the way they're going to
win what they're going to do is
be careful what you wish for the last
thing you want
is aoc doing a federal commission that's
managing the media
well i wanted to ask you if there's
anything you want to announce
uh but i'm not going to ask you because
i figure when you're ready to announce
it you will
thank you governor everybody go to
stanfordamericapac.com
thank you